y la renuncia del ministro carrasquilla
ni la retirada de la reforma tributaria
van a frenar a la minga indígena estamos
aquí en la universidad del valle en cali
donde más de 1500 indígenas están
concentrados algunos de los
representantes nos han explicado que se
van a quedar en cali ya que es el
principal foco de resistencia del país
colombiano además han denunciado los
abusos policiales que también han
denunciado otras organizaciones
humanitarias y además han dicho que hace
falta que un consenso de país para
responder a las necesidades de todos los
colombianos
hablamos con algunas de las
representantes indígenas aquí presentes
los motivos tienen que ver con el
derecho a la vida el derecho a la
democracia porque hoy está en riesgo la
democracia se está desmantelando los
derechos fundamentales de los indígenas
de los campesinos de los afrocolombianos
de los ciudadanos como es el tema de la
reforma agraria que se retiró tributaria
pero que se retiró
con el fin de reestructurarlo y en la
reestructuración puede ser mucho más
peligrosa que la que ya está está
demostrado que todas son pacíficas
porque eso se ha hecho desde un inicio
pero hemos visto la represión brutal y
el uso desmedido de la fuerza pública en
un asuntos que ya estamos demandadas
demandando en este momento ahí están los
muertos ahí están los heridos de los
manifestantes y cuya responsabilidad
recae en la fuerza pública es tan
evidente que ellos ya lo están asumiendo
y han dicho que van a entrar a
investigar